[Musik]
mit diesem Plakat möchte badri gleich
Russen am Flughafen von Tiflis empfangen
der 22-Jährige Georgier will nicht dass
sein Land 10.000 Menschen aus Russland
Zuflucht bietet er fragt sich warum die
Menschen erst jetzt ihr Land verlassen
der Krieg dauere ja immerhin schon acht
Monate
ist es geht um die Menschen die Putins
Regime eigentlich stützen die auf der
einen Seite den Krieg und die Repression
gegen die Ukraine unterstützt haben aber
sich dann als ihr Leben in Gefahr war
dazu entschieden haben wegzulaufen und
in Georgien Schutz zu suchen
und so steht auf seinem Schild Grüße an
alle russischen Deserteure
badri ist Teil der Jugendorganisation
girci sie sind strikt Anti Russisch und
für Solidarität mit der Ukraine in einem
eigenen Studio produzieren sie Youtube
Inhalte ihre Meinung ist klar Russland
ist eine Besatzungsmacht seit 2018
russische Truppen in der prasien und
südostizien präsent völkerrechtlich
gehören diese Gebiete allerdings zu
Georgien
wir begleiten badri heute zum Flughafen
in einer halben Stunde landet ein
Flugzeug aus der aserbaidschanischen
Hauptstadt Baku zur Zeit sind solche
Flüge voller Russen
ich mache mir keine Sorgen bei dieser
Aktion ganz im Gegenteil ich glaube ich
mache das Richtige und mehr Menschen
sollten das auch tun
über 70.000 Russen sind seit der
Ankündigung Putins zur teilmobil-machung
am 21 September nach Georgien geflohen
viele kamen auch schon vorher ins Land
schätzungen gehen von insgesamt 300.000
aus die meisten stranden hier in der
Hauptstadt Tiflis in der ganzen Stadt
ist zu sehen und zu spüren dass viele
Georgier an der Seite der Ukraine stehen
im Kaukasuskrieg 2008 kam die russische
Armee Tiflis sehr nahe nur 40 km standen
die Panzer vor den Toren der Stadt
vielen georgien ist das noch sehr
präsent viele haben Angst dass sich die
Geschichte wiederholt
diese Stimmung in Georgien überträgt
sich auch auf die Politik des Landes wir
treffen den Oppositionspolitiker mamuka
casaraze er kritisiert die Regierung als
pro Russisch und fordert eine härtere
Gangart gegenüber Russen
wir sind das einzige Land im Kaukasus
das ein einjähriges Visum für russische
Besucher ausgibt
Aserbaidschan zum Beispiel hat nur 90
Tage
unsere Partei will ein Gesetz einbringen
um diese Regel zu ändern
[Musik]
das ist nur eine Forderung der
Opposition eine andere ist die
Ausweisung von denen die sich nicht klar
gegen die russische Invasion in der
Ukraine stellen die Regierung Georgiens
hat sich noch nicht klar positioniert
doch der Druck auf sie wächst
visumsverkürzungen und die Gefahr von
Ausweisungen Georgien wäre für viele
Russen nicht mehr so attraktiv wie jetzt
ohne gesundheitsgenehmigung müssten die
meisten das Land nach drei Monaten
wieder verlassen das macht vielen Sorge
auch Daria und Dimitri sie sind vor drei
Wochen geflohen und wollen sich jetzt
eigentlich in Tiflis ein neues Leben
aufbauen
es war sehr schwierig eine Wohnung zu
finden da auf dem Wohnungsmarkt viel los
war gerade Ende September als viele
Menschen hierhergekommen sind die Preise
sind enorm angestiegen und die Wohnungen
waren schnell vermietet
Rückblick wir treffen Daria und Dimitri
das erste Mal am 27 September an der
Georgisch russischen Grenze
es sind die Tage nach der Verkündung der
teilmobilisierung als Tausende Russen
aus ihrem Land fliehen
seitdem ist viel passiert Daria und
Dimitri sind den Tiflis angekommen das
erste was sie machen mussten war ein
bankkontor eröffnen russische
Kreditkarten funktionieren hier nicht
drei Wochen lang haben sie jetzt die
neue Stadt entdeckt und würden gerne
bleiben
[Musik]
die Atmosphäre hier ist freier das merkt
man deutlich
nicht zum Krieg ein und nötig dich auch
nicht dazu Menschen zu töten
Dimitri kann hier weiter als
Programmierer arbeiten sein
internationaler Arbeitgeber sitzt in der
Türkei Daria ist auf der Suche nach
Arbeit zurück nach Russland wollen beide
nicht
auch Georgi ist neu in der Stadt der
19-Jährige ist aus einem kleinen
georgischen Bergdorf nach Tiflis gezogen
um hier zu studieren seine Wohnung hat
keine Tür und im Bad muss man mit einem
Eimer spülen
die Küche ist klein und einfach und
gleich neben dem Herd ist auch die
Dusche das Schlafzimmer hat zehn
Quadratmeter erteilt es sich mit seiner
Schwester
wir haben sehr viele Besucher aus
anderen Ländern vor allem aus Russland
deswegen haben die Vermieter alle ihre
Preise erhöht
vor allem die vom Land haben es schwer
wir können nicht so viel bezahlen und
müssen eine Wohnung finden die billig
und trotzdem gut ist
aber es ist schwer eine gute Wohnung zu
finden selbst mit 300 bis 400 Jahre
Georgi und seine Schwester Zahlen für
diese Wohnung jetzt 300 Lari das sind
umgerechnet 110 Euro für Georgi ist das
viel Geld die Wohnung die er dafür
bekommt ist inakzeptabel aber er findet
keine bessere seine Wut auf die
russischen Einwanderer wächst
[Musik]
klar bin ich wütend ich finde erst
sollte man sich um die Georgier kümmern
dann um alle anderen wie die Russen
viele Russen sind schon seit Monaten in
der Stadt geflohen gleich nach Beginn
der Kämpfe in der Ukraine ein paar
Straßenzüge entfernt von georgis Wohnung
treffen wir Katharina kiltau sie ist
Putin Kritikerin und musste Russland
Anfang März verlassen in ihrem
Heimatland gilt sie als ausländische
Agentin eine Feindin des Volkes
auszuwandern ist nicht so angenehm und
toll wie manche es sich vorstellen das
ist ein fremdes Land eine fremde Stadt
das sind neue Menschen ein neuer Alltag
ein neues Leben an das man sich gewöhnen
muss
Katharina kümmert sich mit vielen
freiwilligen um die die jetzt in der
Stadt ankommen sie vermittelt Wohnungen
Arbeitsplätze und organisiert
Informationsveranstaltungen das kleine
Haus in der Altstadt ist so zur
Anlaufstelle für Russen geworden
ich werde jetzt oft gefragt ob ich viele
z-anhänger treffe die aus Russland
kommen also Menschen die zwar die
russische Politik und Putin unterstützen
aber sich nicht am Krieg beteiligen
wollen ich habe hier noch niemanden
getroffen der so denkt und ich hoffe es
bleibt so weil das hier ist der falsche
Ort für diese Menschen
der Verein von Katharina hat am Eingang
eine Alternative russische Flagge
aufgehängt ohne das Rot sie soll für ein
offeneres demokratischeres Russland
stehen
Katharina will uns zeigen wie russische
Männer wohnen die alleine und ohne Geld
in diesen Tagen in Tiflis ankommen
in einer heruntergekommenen Straße in
der Altstadt führt sie uns in einen
Keller
hier wohnen zurzeit 14 Männer auf
engstem Raum es ist stickig und es
riecht nach dem Ruß der Kamine
wir treffen Alexander einen Kosaken aus
grasnodar der 35-Jährige wäre wohl
eingezogen worden doch bevor er den
Bescheid bekommen hat ist er geflohen
ich habe nur eine Tasche mitgenommen und
nicht so viele Sachen
ein paar Hemden und zwei oder drei Paar
Schuhe
alexander ist seit einer Woche in Tiflis
besonders willkommen fühlt er sich nicht
einmal wurde er auf der Straße beleidigt
weil sein Auto ein russisches
Kennzeichen hat
man spürt es es ist Abneigung gegenüber
Russen die Menschen hier haben Angst
dass irgendwann die russische Armee
kommt um russische Interessen zu
schützen wenn zu viele Russen hier sind
Alexander sieht sich selbst nicht als
Russe wie zum Beweis packt er aus seiner
Reisetasche die Flagge der Exil Kosaken
aus zurück nach Russland will er nicht
mehr er möchte nicht kämpfen für ein
Land das er selbst nicht als Heimat
sieht
zurück bei badri und seinen Freunden am
Flughafen von Tiflis sie sind auf dem
Weg in die Ankunftshalle gleich müssten
die ersten Russen ankommen der Flug aus
Baku ist bereits gelandet sie
positionieren sich direkt am Ausgang und
empfangen die ankommenden Russen mit den
Worten Grüße an alle russischen
Deserteure
wir werden nicht damit aufhören unsere
Stimme gegenüber Russland wird lauter
wir wollen ihnen klarmachen ihr seid
Besitzer
es rumort in der georgischen Hauptstadt
viele Georgier wollen nichts mehr mit
Russland zu tun haben ihr Blick geht
Richtung Westen das Land wird sich mit
der Tatsache auseinandersetzen müssen
das hunderttausende Russen im Land sind
und hier dauerhaft leben wollen
russische geflüchtete aufnehmen und
gleichzeitig an der Seite der Ukraine
stehen für Georgien ist das nicht immer
ganz einfach in Polen kommen seit Beginn
der Kämpfe in der Ukraine immer mehr
geflüchtete aus der Ukraine an und wie
das Land damit umgeht das zeigt meine
Kollegin Natalie Steger
wer in der Ukraine bleibt dem droht ein
bitterkalter Winter doch die Menschen
dort die machen einfach weiter und
lassen sich davon nicht abschrecken wie
man die Kollegin Katrin Eigendorf zeigt
wenn euch das alles gefallen hat was wir
so machen vom ZDF und vom Ausland
Journal dann liked gerne unsere Beiträge
kommentiert oder abonniert gleich den